and let's start today in
houston where things are a bit confusing
because david culley the new head coach
of the houston texans and
i i think he's in an unwinnable
situation when it
comes to a lot of things but the most
obvious issue with the texans miles is
the status of quarterback deshaun watson
and on the same day that kali was due to
have
a pre-free agency press conference or
post-combine that didn't happen press
conference or whatever it was he was
having a press conference today before
that though
word emerged of an interview that he did
with the huddle and flow
podcast jim trotter steve weish here is
kali
talking to waishan trotter about desean
watson
will desean watson be the starting
quarterback for the houston texans in
2021
he is our starting quarterback as of
right now he is our starting quarterback
things happen between now and then
and then we'll see what happens he is
our starting quarterback
right okay that's right right now and
hopefully in the future
i am excited to be here one of the
reasons i'm excited to be here is
because of deshawn watson
and regardless of what's happening
outside this building which
i quite frankly fellas i don't hear
or read or listen to what happens
outside this building
i don't but the point is inside this
building
inside this organization we feel
positive
about moving forward with this football
team with deshaun watson
okay starting quarterback right now
right now
was emphasized a couple of times he also
said we want guys who are all in that
reminds me of mike tomlin line we want
volunteers not hostages and every time i
hear that i think then why do you have
draft picks
why do you have draft picks draft draft
picks are not volunteers they're
hostages they
they involuntarily must join your team
what they should all be free agents you
should dispense with all your draft
picks
and just sign undrafted free agents if
you want volunteers not hostages but
that's what he said miles and i think
the fair takeaway was
as jim trotter pointed out the texans
have warmed up to the reality
that they're going to have to trade
desean watson yeah
for sure look i think when you hear the
words right now you start to think about
what the rams were saying about jared
goff right that's what sean mcvay said
just after the season he's our
quarterback right now les snead started
talking about jared goff
a little bit after the season he is our
quarterback at the moment and then a few
days later
jared goff had been agreed to be traded
to the detroit lions and they
got matthew stafford in return so when
you start hearing the words like
right now and jim trotter then takes
from that
yeah they are starting to soften their
stance and that's why he
jim trotter said he believes that desean
watson will be traded
because of the words that david culler
used so yes i think that that was a
really
it was the right conclusion to come to
basically when you hear what david
culley was saying
and it's that specifically when you hear
the words right now and then he even
says
those things are subject to change well
then that's i think the logical
conclusion that you can come to there
mike
and apparently things were subject to
change because kali
a couple of hours hours ago had his
press conference
here he is speaking to reporters when
asked about
deshaun watson
hey coach connolly you've said
repeatedly the team is committed to
deshaun watson are is he committed to
you and the team
yes he is how do you know that
well he's a houston texan and and and
again
i i know that i feel like that with the
commitment that we've made to him and
and i feel like that that same
commitment will be there
uh or with us also moving forward
that awkward moment was just i'd say
i don't know five percent of the various
answers cully gave about deshaun watson
and it was all
from this notion of we're committed to
deshaun watson
we and he wouldn't delve into his
conversations with deshaun watson but
i'm looking at the post that
that i i did based on the actual quotes
from the press conference
he said i don't know about him not
wanting to be a houston texan well
you've spoken to him and it's
been reported that he made it clear he
doesn't want to be a texan so
i think someone made it clear to david
culley thou shalt not say anything to
suggest that we may possibly be trading
deshaun watson
either because colley got it wrong or
miles i think more likely part of their
effort to get maximum return for deshaun
watson is to act like
they aren't going to trade him that
maybe this idea that they're holding
firm and holding
out and holding fast in their notion
that he's not going to be traded is the
thing that maybe gets them
an even better package for desean watson
by the time it's all said and done but i
don't know how many people are going to
believe that when you juxtapose
what he said to weish and trotter to
what he said to the media today
yeah yeah it to me it was very obvious
that somebody said to david culley
hey man that's not the stance that we're
going to take publicly onto sean watson
right now
so you really can't go out there and say
that because the thing that was
interesting to me about that presser was
at first
he was basically saying you know i'm
going to defer all those personnel
things that's going to be our gm nicosia
that's where that really goes
and then as he kept having to answer
questions he started saying the things
about the commitment
and that that answer that he had where
he says you know i
desean watson is committed to us because
we're committed to him and all that
that's kind of ludicrous
like what kind of reporting have we all
seen where
we know that he had a meeting with sean
watson and obviously he doesn't want to
say what the contents of that meeting
were
but we all know that deshaun watson
wants out and this whole notion of
i don't hear or see anything that's
going on
outside the building it's not true there
are people who are paid
in all of these organizations to make
sure that the head coach knows exactly
what's going on and what's being said
about the organization from the outside
of it so
just i understand that david culley is
in a very tough spot right now
but the whole thing is just so weird
mike
like we all know i think the way that
this has to end
because deshawn watson's made it clear
he's not playing for them anymore
so despite whatever their public stance
is right now despite whatever price
they think they want to drive up at the
end of the day desean watson is probably
going to be traded
this is an example of what dysfunctional
teams
do this just underscores that the texans
right now
are a mess and that david culley
in the first instance couldn't properly
implement the intended external message
that we're all in with deshaun watson
we're not
wavering on anything with desean watson
that's where we are that's what we're
doing and
this even goes back to the culli
introductory press conference when nick
casario's words
fairly could be interpreted as the door
is open for something he just didn't say
the door is open
for something and maybe they are
intending through confusion
to maximize what they get for deshaun
watson but i don't think so i think this
is just
the latest tangible evidence of a team
that has
lost its way has no idea how to get back
on track in part because i've yet to see
that they've replaced amy palcik as the
head of pr i don't know who's handling
the pr
there now at a high level at a vp level
and secondly you've got a guy
in jack easterby who is unfit to be the
executive vp of football operations in
houston texans and when you have someone
in a job like that who isn't fit to have
that job
dysfunction is the expected result
because he doesn't know what he doesn't
know and he doesn't know how to go about
doing the thing that he has no idea how
to do
and this is the kind of stuff that you
get when you have that kind of
management of your football operation
miles
no doubt about it and that was another
interesting answer that david culley had
in that press conference it was well
what exactly is jack easterby's role in
personnel
and then he sort of started talking
about well nick is the general manager
and
jack easterby is the vice president of
football operations and that means
he does things like scheduling and he's
involved in all kinds of things and he
does a great job with
everything that he does in the
organization and it's kind of like well
that's not really a sufficient
answer and also it really doesn't tell
you exactly what jackie easterbee is
doing on a day-to-day basis when it
comes to personnel so no matter what you
want to
say about nick casario and the fact that
he is the gm
yes that's very true but we all know
that jack easterby
has the ear of cal mcnair and that's the
owner and there's nobody higher up in
the organization than the owner so
when these things happen it's right
you're right mike it just speaks to the
kind of dysfunction
that is happening right now with that
houston team
it is really just a no-win situation for
the guy i think
who is a coach right now in in david
culley there's just no way to win right
now i don't know
how this guy is going to be able to have
a successful
first season because of everything
that's going on it's just
a lot and and i there's a part of me
that kind of feels bad for it because
this is his first opportunity to be a
head coach and
when you look at what the situation is
it's just
really really really dysfunctional
one of the things i love about the nfl
not not that i think it's a great thing
it's a bad thing but it's a reality of
pro football
the billion dollar football operations
that are
highly supposedly specialized and
technical and
refined and everything's put in place
for a certain purpose and then
every team is essentially owned and
operated by a monarchy
where the the the power goes
from from generation to generation or
sibling to sibling or husband to wife or
wife to husband or
or whoever it it doesn't get sold
when the person who's in charge of it
dies it passes to someone in the family
and that sets the stage for the
possibility
of dysfunction and usually through that
dysfunction
these teams still print money because
you have to try this is brewster's
millions on steroids to try to lose
money
as an nfl team yeah you just can't lose
money
but you can't have a team that has no
idea what it's doing
if that that prince in this case who
takes over the team
hires a jester to be in charge of the
football operation
and nobody has the self-awareness to
understand
how badly this is going and how badly it
will continue to go
yeah there's a football team a helmet
behind me of the cleveland browns that
knows pretty much exactly what you're
talking about i mean
when al lerner passed away there in the
early 2000s his team passed on to randy
lerner
and that team was just just the epitome
of dysfunction for over a decade and
then it still was really until
i guess kind of last year basically when
they finally hired andrew barry to take
over the football operation and kevin
stefanski so
when you have this kind of deal when you
have somebody who's an owner that is
overwhelmed and basically
doesn't have a good gauge of what he is
doing and is starting to trust
the wrong people and i think we can
pretty definitively say
that trusting jack easterby seems like
he's trusting the wrong person
based on all of the different reports
that have come out of there
in houston this is the kind of thing
that starts to happen you have your head
coach
saying something on the same day to a
podcast
that is different hours later than what
he's saying in a press conference
that is just not good it is just the
epitome of dysfunction
and houston has to do something in order
to figure this out and honestly i think
the most competent thing that they could
do
is trade desean watson and get a good
young quarterback in return
and let me give you an example of the
failure of having a comprehensive media
strategy and pr strategy like the texans
apparently do at this point
the last thing they should have done is
have this this ricochet
of kali's words to the huddle and flow
podcast
being chased almost immediately by this
press conference and such a conflicting
message
and this is why you have someone in pr
who asks the questions okay when is this
podcast airing when is it debuting
and you work with the coach because you
understand it's coming out the same day
as the press conference and
we need to be sure our message messaging
is on point as to deshaun watson and
here's what we're going to say and you
understand that right
and that just clearly isn't there it's
clearly not there and
when when everything works well you
don't notice it
it's when it doesn't work well that it
becomes
conspicuous and we say what the hell are
they doing and this was a what the hell
are they doing kind of a day for the
texans
that all traces back to the fact that
they just don't have
ultimately the right person in place to
run the football operation and then that
person is
moving on from people for the wrong
reasons and the people who
end up in some of these key jobs either
are over their skis
you know that that was my listening to
cully today and i feel bad for the guy i
mean
this is a guy who was a career position
coach who was never
mentioned as a potential head coach at
the nfl level
never ever ever name has never been on
the radar screen and there are plenty of
lifetime assistant nfl coaches
who you know they'll have a job they
fill a role
they serve a purpose they'll never be a
head coach and that was kali he was in
that category
and watching him listening to him
inescapable conclusion
he's over his skis well it's not a
surprise jack easterby
over his skis who's ever in charge of pr
clearly over their skis owner over his
skis
that's that's it they should change the
logo to a
a bull on skis that are turned upside
down because everybody's over their skis
the only one who probably isn't is nick
casario and he's likely
losing his mind every day because he's
surrounded by people who are over their
skis
yeah i i have to imagine that when nick
cassario
heard the what was coming out of that
podcast today
and probably initially saw jim trotter's
tweet whenever that came out in the
early afternoon today he probably
just put his head in his hands like i
can't believe this you know
because he was pretty staunch in saying
exactly what the messaging was we're not
trading deshaun watson we're not trading
deshaun watson and all the reporting out
of there
has been that that's what they want to
continue to do
but the other thing is though where's
nick casario man
now why isn't he out there answering the
questions because ultimately
if it is the general manager's job to
to take care of personnel and he's the
one that's going to be executing whether
or not there's a trade
then he's the one who really should be
out there answering these questions
and for all the people that you just
mentioned mike he is the one who
supposedly not over his skis
then he should be the one who is in the
off season answering questions
about what transactions the texans are
or are not going to make
you know what i would have done what i
would have recommended not that anyone
should ever listen to me but hey if
if we're gonna go with people who are
over their skis then give me a couple of
polls
and let me head down the the ramp but
what i would have done i would have
cancelled the press conference today
miles
i i would i would have said hey we we
got to do you know let's say coach is
sick i hate i hate having to
endorse a flat-out pre-verification like
that but i'd say
why we just can't do it no i'm going to
give a reason we're going to do it next
week
because we need to we need to have a few
days
to think about what he's going to say in
light of what he said on that podcast
how do we change our messaging
because we can't have this we can't have
this bang bang of
he's our quarterback right now to
throwing him out there
into this pit where he's got to try to
sell over and over again and i'm
surprised frankly maybe they were lucky
that the press conference happened so
quickly in time
after the quotes came out because i
didn't get the impression
that any of the reporters on that call
were aware of what was said to weishan
trotter because nobody built that into a
question nobody said either directly
indirectly
you've characterized desean watson is
your quarterback right now what do you
mean by that
so they i think they got a little lucky
now the end result is still a mess
but it could have been worse if one of
those folks would have been aware
of what kelly had said to trotter and
weish they could have
really gone after him and put him in
even more of a box than he was put in
yeah and i think part of that was that
trotter's tweet
came out i believe before the presser
but we didn't have an exact quote so if
i if i
have the timeline correctly in my mind
after the press conference was over
that's when i believe i first saw
trotter and weiss tweet the full quote
of what that was from david cully and
then they both put it
on twitter and that's i think i
retweeted it saying look like
between the time this was recorded and
the time that david culley's presser
happened somebody came to him and said
hey man you can't you cannot
characterize what's going on with the
sean watson in this way so
i think you're right it might have just
been that
they didn't have the reporters in
houston did not have the full quotes of
what david culley had said before
and so then they couldn't use his words
and ask him that question because
yeah it just the whole thing was just
weird
in that way it's just he's saying
something completely different
than what he had said presumably hours
before that mic
i think that i'm looking back at the
tweets or the texts excuse me that we
exchange
among the pft writers and mds said that
the tweet from trotter
said watson's on the roster right now
and that's when i said hey i think
colleen has a press conference soon and
i looked it up
it was starting in 15 minutes so it was
a limited window for anybody to figure
out what was happening but
hopefully nick casario will be talking
soon and he'll get to deal with the
aftermath of today's mess
that was created by the houston texans
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports